hi I'm Marcia Davis a registered
dietitian nutritionist in private
practice and media and communications I
am going to be reviewing some popular
kpop diets and looking at the good the
bad and the ugly in these diets
so the first diet that we're looking at
is was popularized by Jen and Jimin from
the k-pop group BTS on this diet Jin
used to have four chicken breast fillets
for almost a year
and it sounds like he didn't have much
else that sounds crazy this diet is
really really extreme and of course
you're going to lose weight on something
like this especially if you're cutting
out all of these other food groups and
nutrients but you will also become
probably malnourished so I would say
this is a no-go and a pretty dangerous
diet I would recommend something with a
lot more balance while chicken is a
great source of protein it shouldn't be
your only meal so I would recommend to
have some chicken along with some grains
some vegetables and some fruits healthy
fats all of these other things that are
really essential to being healthy and
nourishing our bodies for proper
functioning this is an interesting one
this is the paper cup diet and this was
popularized by the girl group Nine Muses
according to this diet plan all the
meals in your day should fit within
three paper cups with some people even
saying that these should be three ounce
paper cups which are pretty tiny and
they should be filled with rice side
dishes and fruits and veggies ideally
the side dishes are low in sodium and
fat and this diet is meant to be a way
to help with portion control but it's
relatively loose in terms of what you
actually put in the cups of course on
this diet you're going to lose weight
because you're limiting your intake of
food so drought
Stickley and eating these tiny portions
now I like the fact that they are
promoting portion control but these
portions are pretty ridiculous
I mean who eats three ounce paper cup
amount of food for an entire meal that
sounds highly restrictive that can lead
to cravings which can lead to binging
and that is just a really unhealthy
cycle to be in I would recommend to go
ahead and eat those three meals a day
and instead of using the paper cups for
portion control use a small to medium
sized plate and focus on eating
mindfully listening to your body's
hunger and fullness cues to tell you
when you've had enough to eat so the
next diet is the morning banana diet so
this calls for a banana or multiple
bananas and room-temperature water for
breakfast you can eat anything you like
for lunch and dinner though preferably
something that's healthy and you have to
eat by 8:00 p.m. you can also have a
mid-afternoon snack which can be a
banana and and then one of the other
components of this is that you have to
go to sleep before midnight this is also
called the awesome banana diet and
supposedly it was designed to help
increase metabolism it's supposed to
encourage healthy eating practices like
getting in more fruit and helping one
become more aware of feelings of hunger
and fullness especially by keeping a
diet journal and those participating in
this diet are supposed to stop eating
when they're about 80% full and this
became popular in Japan South Korea and
Taiwan after it went viral on Japan's
social networks and was featured on TV
after the feature bananas flew off the
shelves saw in young is the k-pop idol
who is most commonly mentioned in
relation to this diet and some people
claim that she lost 6 kilograms which is
about 12 pounds within 4 weeks due to
this diet so I guess what she was eating
is 1 to 2 bananas in the morning 2 cups
of water healthy non greasy
in lunch half a banana or one banana
when feeling hungry as a snack and for
dinner she would have a Korean meal
mostly composed of rice and herbs I see
a few really great things here the fact
that there's a lot of flexibility
throughout the day and the fact that
you're getting more fruit intake but the
fact that it's kind of rigidly limiting
it to bananas and telling people to eat
multiple bananas throughout the day
seems a little bit silly also in the
morning you may need something more
substantial than just a banana which is
you know just carbs and sugar I
recommend that people have something
that has a little bit more protein in
the morning so it's a personal decision
but I think this isn't too restrictive
so it's not it's not so terrible but I
think there are there are better ways to
eat than being on the banana diet
our next diet is called the deadly diet
this was popularized by Korean singer
Lee Seung who revealed his post diet
body in which he lost as much as 30
kilograms on this extreme diet plan
which is described as eating chicken
breasts with salad without dressing when
starving you can snack on a few almonds
you're supposed to take vitamin C and
multivitamins regularly drink twice as
much water and all other foods are not
allowed he also described his workouts
saying to do lots of ABS weight training
speed walking and he said don't do it
all at once when it gets too hard rest
for a day and eat as much as you want
exercise should always be done happy
happy don't strain yourself and some
people have said that the name of the
diet came from critics who questioned
the small portions and called the diet
deadly I would agree this is pretty
pretty extreme eating only chicken
breasts and salad and snacking out a few
almonds is not really advised this can
lead to really low blood sugar nutrient
deficiencies can also make you
constipated because you're not getting
very many whole grain no whole grains at
all so your
missing out on a lot of fiber and a lot
of other nutrients and I would imagine
that you'd probably have pretty low
energy if you did this for more than a
few days instead of this what I would
recommend is making the beet meals a lot
more balanced so if you're going to have
the chicken and the salad including some
sort of healthy grain with some sort of
whole-grain like brown rice or whole
grain toast switching it up with a
little bit more variety in the diet so
you're not just eating chicken every
single day because you're probably gonna
get sick of that pretty quick
so our next fad diet is from so young of
the group AOA and according to this
regimen there is really strict portion
control you can only eat certain foods
and there's even more extreme methods
like doing only liquids in one of the
Korean TV shows it was revealed that so
Hyun was only allowed to eat sweet
potato chicken breasts and boiled eggs
sounds like she potentially cried
because of hunger while being on this
diet that's not a good sign now in a
recent interview she said that it was
all lies and that she didn't actually do
this diet which is pretty good news
because I think this diet is really
extreme the sweet potatoes are good
source of carbs and some vitamins
vitamin A the chicken breasts and boiled
eggs are great sources of protein
however you're missing all the greens
all the grains a lot of other fruits and
veggies so this is super restrictive and
I would imagine that if anyone tried
this they would probably cry from hunger
as well
our next fad kpop diet is supposedly
popularized by park boom of the group
2ne1 supposedly she was on a one food
diet where for periods of time she would
only eat corn lettuce or watermelon
however her trainer supposedly set the
record straight
said that this was a distortion and that
she was eating watermelon instead of
rice the trainer was trying to shift her
more western-style diet into a healthier
diet which included five meals a day
so three main meals and two snacks meals
with corn and nuts because those were
some of her favorite foods so it sounds
like these rumors of just eating the
corn maybe got started that way they
also said that watermelon is a great
fruit that's a Sheetz and it was only
chosen to help block out her snacking it
wasn't eaten as a substitute for other
meals or other foods and I guess she
also wanted to set the record straight
however the trainer did give her a
strict diet menu and a diet planner to
record her meals which was supposed to
help reinforce her healthy eating habits
I like the fact that she was tracking
her meals and working on shifting to
healthier habits having three meals a
day and two snacks I think that's a
great way to eat I definitely would
never recommend a one food diet to any
of my patients or clients that is also
disordered eating and a way to miss out
on a lot of nutrients and potentially
even mess up your metabolism so I'm glad
that she set the record straight and
said that she didn't actually follow a
one food diet I think a lot of these
stars feel a lot of pressure to look a
certain way
probably in a short amount of time and
they do really extreme things to try and
achieve that and as a health expert I
would never recommend doing something
like this to anyone including these
stars because it can lead to eating
disordered habits even health issues you
might see the extreme results but
they're probably very temporary and very
unhealthy my recommendation would be to
seek out qualified professional guidance
from someone like a registered dietician
nutritionist
help you meet your specific needs and
goals instead of following something
that's really extreme and even dangerous
that you see online
[Music]